conservatives are celebrating as a
transvestite YouTube Star says that the
leftist gender ideologues have gone too
far
I didn't tell all the other I
think what other Vive in them
yeah and all that extra that we added
during the pandemics everyone's so bored
on their houses they just started to
make up more more stuff yeah that's
where the conservatives like me because
I'm just real yeah you do have a
conservative to them you're trans your
male or your female
and you're standing on that so mad when
I say that how are you with they what
the does that mean as stupid as
what it is yeah but you need someone
like me that looks like me to say it
because if you say it it turns into your
homophobic you hate trans people you
hate gays and it's just how you feel you
don't hate anyone you just
think it's stupid
that guy is Jeffrey steininger goes by
the stage name Jeffrey Starr and a
number of conservatives a fairly
prominent conservatives are lauding him
for saying enough is enough with the
non-binary they them gender pronouns and
all I can think is
this is how conservatives always lose
this is the new line this is the new
Overton window of acceptable political
discourse in 2023 the line is
transgenderism is fine but non-binary is
crazy yeah you tell them Jeffrey
Democrats they're the real transphobes
good grief
this is what always happens
50 years ago conservatives said
okay feminism is fine but homosexuality
is crazy then 30 years ago conservatives
said okay homosexuality is fine but gay
marriage is crazy then 10 years ago
conservatives said okay gay marriage is
fine but transgenderism is crazy and now
in the year of Our Lord 2023
conservatives are saying
you know it okay transgenderism's fine
but this non-binary stuff is crazy
they're saying transgenderism is fine
but wait until they turn 18 to chop them
up transgenderism is fine but wait until
they turn nine to teach them about it in
school
that's in one of the most conservative
States on this issue they say wait till
eight once they turn nine then you can
talk about it this is how we lose
because we fail to understand what the
left understands which is that if you
accept the left's basic premises those
premises are eventually going to be
taken to their logical conclusions if
you accept the premise in this case that
men and women are basically the same you
can start that out in the 70s you can
start that out with feminism you are
going to end up here you can try to slow
it down a little bit
you can try in vain to push pause on the
unfolding of history based on certain
premises but you're never going to stop
it you're certainly never going to stop
it at transgenderism is fine but
non-binary is crazy in fact the guy who
articulated that view
too much conservative Fanfare is already
walking it back
anyone that is trying to make it seem
like I said that non-binary people don't
exist I never said that record this
right now never said it you're putting
words in my mouth I said I don't like
the pronouns and I don't agree with them
I never said that they don't exist
I'm a freak I'm a part of the lgbtq
community
I'm pansexual I'm bisexual whatever the
you want to call me I don't like
labels I like guys I like girls I like
sleeping with both but I love men
whatever you think that it that means to
you I don't care label it however you
want but don't put words in my mouth I
do not agree with a few things I'm old
school but this new all these 30 Terms
girl stop stop complicating everything
just chill take a hit relax and don't
put words in my mouth
there he is Jeffree Star Mr Conservative
that's the most conservative guy in
America 30 years from now
I'm only half joking 30 years from now
it's going to be 20 53 we're gonna say
man you remember that far right winger
Jeffree Star that's what's going to
happen if the American right doesn't
wake up and start offering people
something other than just the leftism of
10 years ago I'm Michael Knowles is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show a really big
show I send like I sound like uh who's
that the most famous uh broadcaster of
all time
now now His Name Escapes Me we got a
really big show really really big show
uh coming up we have an American Service
member who is suffering what seems to be
a vaccine injury because of the vaccine
mandate uh we're gonna chat about it a
little bit even on YouTube we'll see if
they shut us down and then we're going
to have a lot more of it over the member
block so stick around until the end of
the show Ed Sullivan that's his name I
can't believe his name escaped me my
favorite comment last week is from Phil
Vedder who says counting down the days
until the government starts cracking
down on coincidence noticing I think
that's already basically against the law
certainly violates the Moray is
established by our ruling Elite but yeah
pretty soon you're going to see a bill
no more notice and coincidences no more
noticing when people have heart attacks
and strokes after they take that vaccine
you're not allowed to notice that sort
of thing
okay now unfortunately people who have
an even semi-proper education do notice
these Trends and when you want to get a
good education you got to check out
Grand Canyon University right now head
on over to
gcu.edu are you ready to take the next
step in your education but struggling to
fit traditional classes into your busy
schedule Grand Canyon University's
online programs are designed to make
earning your degree easy and accessible
no matter your age or stage in life I
really love Grand Canyon University I
visited Grand Canyon University some
years ago I was giving a speech for yaf
I just love the students I love the
whole vibe of the place whether you're a
busy professional looking to advance
your career or a stay-at-home parent
juggling family responsibilities their
online courses give you the flexibility
you need to learn on your own terms
Grand Canyon University specializes in
helping you fit your bachelor's Master's
or doctoral degree into your busy day
from scholarships to customized
scheduling your grad situation team led
by your own GCU counselor provides you
with the personal support you need to
succeed so why wait if you are ready to
take your education to the next level
you need Grand Canyon University find
your purpose at Grand Canyon University
gcu.edu that is gcu.edu
speaking of the sexual Revolution you
remember that teacher that male teacher
up in Canada who showed up to school
with the gigantic prosthetic breasts I
think they were size Z I'm not joking
about that and he showed up and he was
had the breasts in shop class
kids were kind of making fun of him and
recording videos and he said look it's
my sexual identity
I'm transgender
I'm a woman
some women have very large breasts
how dare you how dare you question my
identity
well
turns out there's a little more to the
story at the time
I said you know there's a chance that
this guy is trolling
and he might just be severely mentally
ill or he's trolling and there were some
rumors online that he was trolling well
here's what we know now he goes by the
name Kayla Lemieux previously when he
was a man when he identified as a man he
went by Carrie and he wears the blonde
wig and the tight tops and all the rest
of it well one of Carrie's neighbors who
chose to remain anonymous just told the
New York Post that Carrie only presents
as a female
in public in very specific public
situations
the neighbor says he wears prosthetic
breasts extremely infrequently he puts
the breasts on to teach occasionally
when he goes for a walk or when the cops
visit but then
this this neighbor I suppose or one of
the neighbors got some photos of this
guy just walking around his neighborhood
and he's just walking around in
sweats and like a t-shirt and it just
looks like a completely normal guy
to which I say
don't hate the player hate the game if
this guy is trolling which he very well
might be
is brilliant it's brilliant
this guy
is a member of the most maligned group
in Western Society the only group that
it is socially acceptable and encouraged
to insult and that it is legal to
discriminate against that is white guys
just regular old white guys
and
by saying I'm actually a woman and
putting on this big ridiculous
prosthetic breast
system and then putting on the wig he's
saying oh no now I'm an oppressed
minority and if you dare
to question this clown show that I'm
putting on
I am going to sue you into Oblivion I am
going to make this an international
incident I'm going to have the jobs of
the administration of this school and so
what happens
he just keeps teaching he's been this
story broke months ago
and he just keeps on teaching
he didn't make the rules of the game
this guy is just playing the game he's
gaming the system
possible look maybe he's just a crazy
guy he could just be a crazy guy but
from what I'm seeing here it's very
possible that he's just gaming the
system to which I say
well done sir
that we could simply tear the system
down but one way to tear systems down is
to reveal them as Preposterous to show
that the emperor has no clothes
he's doing a great job of that whether
he wants to or not whether that's the
intention or not
white guys regular old white guys are
considered the scum of the earth this is
a public view now there's a tick tock
just went viral of an Asian woman
explaining how much she doesn't like
white people
hi there you must be new to my account I
say what to remind people that oh
Supremacy is everywhere because in order
for True equality to happen or Supremacy
has to be dismantled and a lot of people
are not even aware of their use of
whiteness unless someone like me points
It Out by calling it white in your case
you as a oink woman telling an Asian
woman how to speak on her account is a
pretty privileged mindset because I
would have never thought to go to your
account and say hey your face is really
annoying you should change your profile
photo I would never say that to you like
that would have never crossed my mind
like who am I to tell you that and you
should have awareness of your actions
you as a woman telling me how to speak
is tone policing and that's a behavior
that's very common among women you may
have not intended that but there are
many women who act exactly like you so
that's why I say what to raise your
awareness because it's so ingrained in
you you may not realize it and maybe
next time when you're about to do the
very same thing my annoying what will
ring in your ear and stop you
so you're welcome
this is just a crazy woman right this is
just a crazy Fringe woman
actually this is the public opinion of
the New York Times The Washington Post
the whole establishment media the
universities the entertainment culture
and the government
white people are bad
what she's saying quite she's she's
making a sound as though she's pulling
up phlegm to spit that's why she's
pronouncing it that way
as as if to say white people are they're
worse than spit they deserve to be spit
upon
that is not just some angry bigoted
lady's opinion that is what is being
taught in schools what's being taught in
schools is that whiteness is
intrinsically evil and needs to be
abolished there are calls to abolish
whiteness in major newspapers and
magazines
it's not just this crazy lady in fact
rather than this crazy lady changing the
culture to hate white people I suspect
it was the other direction I suspect the
culture which constantly reinforces the
idea that whiteness is bad and white
people should be ashamed of themselves
and and white privilege and white Nas I
guess is something to be abolished
very likely that cultural view which
long predates that woman
helped to form her views
this is the view on the admissions
committees this is the view in hiring
practices this is the view of the
government which is dedicating resources
and energy toward dismantling whiteness
and all the rest of it this is
your country do not write that crazy
lady off it's it's just like the Jeffree
Star video
you you think that we're living in the
same culture that we've been living in
your whole life but that Overton window
of acceptable political dialogue has
moved so radically far to the left that
now we're in the place where saying hey
white people aren't
the absolute devil
is a somewhat controversial opinion I
don't know that you're allowed to voice
that
at work
in the government or in your schools not
great stuff all right and we've got a
we've got to heal our country when you
want to heal your country one part of
that is healing your body when you want
to heal your body you got to check out
Jace medical right now go to
jacemedical.com use promo code Knowles
have you gone to the store let's say you
go to the grocery store recently not
been able to find something eggs milk
then when you do find them you say wait
a second these eggs are almost nine
dollars per dozen there are shortages
and you should be concerned shortages
don't just happen during crises like
Global pandemics or natural disasters
they happen every day and you need to be
prepared for them a great way to start
preparing is with the Jace case from
Jace medical the Jace case is a pack of
five different courses of antibiotics
that you can use to treat a whole host
of bacterial illnesses all you have to
do is fill out a simple online form your
information is reviewed by a board
certified physician your medication will
be dispensed by a licensed Pharmacy and
a fraction of the regular cost then you
are prepared it can be out of mind you
get peace of mind be like the Knowles is
okay be prepared go to jacemedical.com
enter code Knowles Canada w-les at
checkout for a discount on your order
that is jacemedical.com promo code
Knowles
speaking of white privilege
we turn our attention again to East
Palestine Ohio
where we are told the water is totally
fine the air is clean again even just a
couple of weeks after this big massive
chemical smell the water is totally safe
to drink except
Water Utilities in Cincinnati and
Northern Kentucky have decided to shut
down their water intake after the spill
this would be the Greater Cincinnati
Water Works and Northern Kentucky water
district they're just going to take some
precautions why just just in case no
because they tested the water and they
found low levels of chemicals from the
toxic spill
in some places had intakes along the
Waterway and they're seeing reports of
fish dying on mass in the local
waterways and they're seeing the East
Palestine residents who are getting
headaches who are developing rashes
because the town has been poisoned
so you're saying well look we just we've
got some low levels of these chemicals
being found so we're going to shut down
the water intake well they can't be that
low if you're going to shut down the
water intake at two of these Utilities
in two different states that seems like
a pretty big problem that everybody is
trying to downplay
I am seeing news of this story reported
in very very few places and the and the
politicians are all trying to downplay
it notice they won't go there Joe Biden
isn't going to East Palestine
there may eventually be enough political
pressure that he has to go you're not
seeing Pete bootage show up to East
Palestine
you're not seeing the Ohio senator
say that he will drink the water from
East Palestine yeah I want to ask you
would you drink the water in East
Palestine and do you think the officials
there who are saying it's safe they
should drink the water too to show the
residents that they they would drink it
well I think they are I mean I talked to
the mayor the mayor said definitively
um emphatically that people can drink
the water the Mayors I don't know if I
don't think the mayor has small kids he
looks a little older to me I I didn't
ask him but about bathing his kids but
he would he has said he would drink this
water right but to show the residents
who are so skeptical do you think that
they well I think he probably is
I think he probably is but I I do think
though as I said when when you know you
hear all this stuff about stock BuyBacks
and they're under investing as you say
in in rail safety the the tracks
themselves in the cars
do you think these Democrat politicians
who are saying the water safety you
think that you know you guys should all
drink the water
well yeah I think they are
well hold on sir you are one of the
politicians you are the Democrat senator
from Ohio you're trying to convince
everybody the water is safe so would you
drink the water and would the local
politicians the mayor of East Palestine
and all the rest would they drink the
water too yeah yeah no I'm pretty sure
they are bro it's a very simple question
will you drink the water
the answer is no
obviously Democrat Sherrod Brown is not
going to take one sip of that water now
the other senator from Ohio JD Vance
who's the Republican he was asked this
question and he said no I wouldn't drink
the water I would drink bottled water
which fortunately for right now is still
being given out for free in the
community but I would not drink the
water because it's poisoned
Sharon Brown doesn't want to admit that
it's poisoned no no I think they are I
think let's move on let's talk about
something else I want to talk about I
don't know gun control or something
anything other than talking about this
major environmental disaster
it's amazing that the Democrats they
only ever want to talk about the
environment they only ever want to talk
about climate everything is related to
climate covid was caused by climate
change food shortages caused by climate
change migration caused by climate
change we've got to save the environment
except when there's a gigantic toxic
chemical spill and then
Move Along Move Along nothing to see
here
that doesn't doesn't make a lot of sense
to me
if the libs care about the environment
which which they don't really and if the
libs care about small town America which
they don't they hate small town America
so if you want to talk about white
privilege I think I think the white
population of East Palestine East
Palestine Ohio is like 90 or something
so we'll write that off that's that's
those rural people those hillbillies
flyover bitter Clinger
get cling to their guns and religion
let small town America die that's what
you're hearing and you're hearing it
from even the politicians
speaking of
scientific ethics
and viral tick tocks there's another
video it's actually somehow more
disturbing than the first two that you
just listened to more disturbing than
the racist Asian lady more disturbing
than Jeffree Star saying listen here
I've got the conservative line trans
bestiality is fine but pedophilia is too
far listen here I'm look I'm totally
fine with molecules involving three
women ten dudes and a billy goat but
when you introduce a rabbit and that's
too far okay this one's actually more
disturbing this is
a couple of fellas in a romantic
relationship with one another
bragging about how they purchased a baby
so this is how we chose our beautiful
egg Donuts um so we wanted her to have
lovely big eyes I wanted her to have
really thick hair because I've had two
hair transplants I wanted her to have a
really wide nice smile and just look
like a kind person yeah and we wanted
her to be creative because we love the
Arts yeah so how it works is you join up
with a egg donor agency and you
literally go through thousands of
students that's what I did I went
through thousand thousand thousands I
shortlisted them sent them to Francis
and let him decide and then we had I had
three or four in front of me and then we
have a few Zoom calls with the ones that
we liked and then the first egg that it
let us down few minutes
let us down yeah human and then by the
third we literally found her and I was
like oh
she's incredible and when we got on the
zoom call we were like be calm place
don't be too Keen
um and luckily she said yes and this is
the result
yay so we were going out we were going
to look to where we could buy our cotton
picker you know so we went to the market
we wanted we knew we wanted a cotton
picker with nice big broad shoulders a
nice thick stocky legs like tree trunks
you know do a great job out there in the
field and so we went the first one
didn't work out second one we couldn't
quite get him at the at the fair but the
third one finally we got him isn't that
great yeah and as a result isn't that
great
call me crazy call me old-fashioned
call me some fuddy duddy I think it's
wrong to buy people
I think that's wrong
and most people seem to agree with that
concept when we talk about the past
they say you know go into a slave market
and
just viewing people as brute animals and
then purchasing them and then
having them as part of our household
that I was wrong we actually we fought a
very bloody war that was
in large part over that issue and now we
just we just do it again instead of
instead of buying black guys we we buy
the eggs of poor women and then we rent
the wombs of other poor women and then
we have purchased ourselves a designer
baby with just the right hair that we
wanted and just the right eyes we knew
we wanted a big nice smile give me oh
sorry lady you're not
that smile's not big enough Move Along
let's open up that catalog
get some more get some more options here
really awful to say nothing of the fact
that then these two men have created a
child
with the express intent of denying that
child his mother
the relationship to one's mother is one
of the most important relationships that
one will ever have in one's life the
care of a mother the nurturing of a
mother
and these men decided to create a child
with the express intent of ripping that
child away from his mother it is the
most evil thing going on in the country
today other than
abortion
other than killing babies in the womb
creating a baby for the purpose of
pulling that baby away from his natural
mother it's so profoundly evil and more
broadly treating people like Commodities
to be purchased on the open market that
is very very evil and it's not just the
Communists that we have to blame for
this and it's not just the radical left
that we have to blame for this
this is a product of capitalism
this is this is just a market
and instead of a regular Market that
we're used to where you can buy tumblers
and you can buy paper and you can buy
all sorts of actual Commodities now we
are commoditizing humans
and the left Bears a lot of
responsibility for that because the left
degrades humanity and denies human
nature as being made in the image and
likeness of God and the right bear is
some responsibility for putting the cart
before the horse and exalting the free
market as a political end unto itself
instead of what it is which is a means
to an end the end being a flourishing
society that recognizes the humanity of
of all people and allows us to to
flourish
in political society as humans
and not just as stuff or brutes or
animals
and we think this is progress we say oh
this is so enlightened that we've moved
the Overton window now where if you
object to that oh you are you're a bigot
you're a terrible terrible person even
the conservatives they'll say look I
have no problem
with two guys uh redefining the
fundamental political institution and I
listen I don't even really have a
problem
with those guys adopting a little
newborn baby or creating a baby in a
test tube or purchasing the eggs from a
woman and then renting the womb from a
woman and say Ukraine and then flying
over and taking the baby from there just
I just think
we shouldn't you shouldn't be able to
I don't know pick their eye color or
something I don't even that's probably
not even a limit anymore there's there's
no limit to that we've moved so
radically far
to the left
folks
it's no secret the libs hate our country
they want to rewrite history
they want to villainize our heroes and
omit key details from the historical
record
such as the fact that on Christmas night
night 17 and 76 George Washington
crossed the Delaware River in a sneak
attack against British forces after
shaving with a Jeremy's razor that's a
that's history okay
you probably didn't learn that in school
few people know that and it's a sad
reflection of our great nation going
woke but like Washington before us you
can fight back against woke tyranny
simply by picking up a magnificent
Jeremy's razor during our 30 off
President's Day Sale it is time that we
celebrate history not cancel it go to
jeremy'sraisers.com today get 30 off any
razor that's jeremy'sraisers.com today
speaking of capitalism
I mentioned the story right at the very
end of last week Bears going into a
little bit the cost of eggs has now
surpassed the cost of beef
dozen eggs right now according to the
U.S Bureau of Labor Statistics dozen
large grade A eggs
4.82 cents in January depending on where
you live if you live in a city if you
get the fancy eggs that sweet little
Elisa makes me buy it could be double
that
a pound of ground beef
4.64 cents
in January 2022 eggs were a buck 93 and
beef was 477 but egg prices have soared
by 70 percent in the last year alone
the economy is faltering crime is on the
rise education is in the doldrums people
don't trust elections anymore because we
don't have faith in our institutions of
government and because the libs keep
changing all the rules right before the
elections
we can't afford eggs we can't afford a
whole host of goods and what is our
president focusing on well he's focusing
on the important issues like giving
ukrainians pensions
and they'll deliver much needed
humanitarian assistance as well as food
water medicine shelter another Aid to
ukrainians displaced by Russians war and
provide aid for those seeking refuge in
other countries from Ukraine and it's
also going to help schools and hospitals
open
it's going to allow pensions and social
support to be paid to the Ukrainian
people so they have something something
in their pocket it's also going to
provide critical resources to address
food shortages around the globe
it's really important those ukrainians
might not have something in their
pockets they might be struggling to go
out and buy the really fancy eggs
you selfish Americans you don't want to
send them another
100 billion dollars
Biden is so serious about the support
for Ukraine that Joe Biden flew to Kiev
in recent days
the White House announced today
President Biden is in Kiev to reaffirm
America's unwavering commitment to
Ukraine's democracy sovereignty and
territorial Integrity the United States
of America will stand with the Ukrainian
people for as long as it takes a lot of
conservatives are very confused by this
and it's too bad
because it's not a very complicated
issue
the United States is a global Empire in
fact we are the most powerful Empire in
the world and we have been for 70 or 80
years now and Ukraine is one of our
Imperial Holdings
we've had other Imperial Holdings over
the years Afghanistan
maybe uh Iraq
the Philippines Guam Hawaii
some Puerto Rico sometimes those
Imperial Holdings become States
sometimes we give them back and we give
them Independence
or relative Independence at least and
sometimes they're in a sort of a middle
ground
and it is quite clear that Ukraine is a
vassal State for the American Empire
that's what the war is about
the war is about Russia wanting to
expand its empire into a more of its
traditional sphere of influence to use
Barack Obama's term and the United
States wanting to expand its Empire and
Stave off the growth of other Empires
and Ukraine which is a buffer state
became a flash point here because of I
think a very mismanaged foreign policy
in which we forgot the value of buffer
States
and NATO wanted to expand even more into
Ukraine Ukraine was talking about
joining the EU and joining NATO Russia
said this is unacceptable Russia wanted
leaders that were more sympathetic to
Russia
America wanted leaders that were more
sympathetic to America and so you've had
this steady escalation certainly since
2014 but really for a long time before
that you had warnings from Fairly
serious American Statesmen and foreign
policy experts people like Sam Nunn
people like George Kennan wrote The Long
Telegram people like Henry Kissinger
people like Daniel Patrick Moynihan
saying NATO really shouldn't expand all
all this far into Eastern Europe NATO
really should be very careful about
expanding into places like Ukraine
because that's going to create a
provocative situation it could lead us
to war and and that's exactly what
happened and so now Biden feels some
responsibility but beyond that just
recognizes that this is an Imperial War
like many many wars throughout the
history of the world and so he's got to
go there and show that he's serious
about maintaining his territorial
holding now whatever you think about
Empire or Nation May a lot of
conservatives want to deny the fact that
America is a global Empire but that's
just like putting your head in the sand
it just is what it is that's just a
historical fact I think back to Pericles
in ancient Athens who observe that it
may have been unwise for Athens to
accumulate the Empire that it did
but regardless it would also very likely
be dangerous to give up that Empire once
you're in it these are just some of the
very difficult problems of History
sometimes the dye is simply cast
my only observation about all of this is
that
the libs know how to wield political
power
it's a point I keep coming back to in
the show
the libs for all their sins for all
their faults for all their empty
promises the libs understand how
political power works
how the real Constitution works not the
capital c constitution written on that
parchment paper that doesn't really
reflect the way the American government
works anymore and hasn't for a long time
they understand the real constitution of
the people in the real way the power is
wielded this is why the left is so much
better at wielding the bureaucracy than
the right is the right ones to deny this
bureaucracy exists the right ones to
legitimize the bureaucracy say it's it's
not to be found in the Constitution
therefore we can ignore it but power is
wielded by the bureaucracy and so the
libs go in and they just wield it
themselves
that's
a lesson that we could learn as
conservatives but we don't want to learn
instead we hear these ridiculous
platitudes by people like Larry Hogan
Larry Hogan is the squish Republican
governor of Maryland Larry Hogan
believes that he's going to run for
president in 2024 and Larry Hogan was
asked about one of the biggest issues
on the right one of the most winning
issues for republicans
which is the curriculum battle the
culture wars in the schools
this is the issue that helped get Glenn
young and elected this is the issue that
helped get Ron DeSantis reelected and
it's really helped him maintain
popularity in Florida this has been a
winning issue all around the country
Larry Hogan says hmm I don't know it
kind of reeks a big government
my question to you is not whether this
is a legitimate issue to be talking
about it's about whether this is the
main issue or not do you view this as
the main issue for 2024 no I think it's
an important issue and I do hear it and
people are concerned about this as I
travel around the country because you
know most people just don't think we
should be talking about you know things
like sex to young kids and the parents
want to be more involved in this
decisions about what their kids are
being taught however uh you know I think
some of this rhetoric is uh you know
some you know demanding that things be
done a certain way or that you can't say
this you can't say that we've got to be
really careful no does it feel like
you're going the other way like it's
sort of like you're on one hand if
Governor DeSantis claiming hey I don't
want all of this but I'm going to tell
you exactly what you can say and I'm
going to tell you what you can't say
well I'm a small government you know
Common Sense conservative and to me it
sounds like big government and uh
authoritarian uh you have to agree with
me and I'm going to tell you what you
can and can't do so but it's an issue
it's not the most important issue I
think more people are concerned about
the economy inflation they're concerned
about crime but education is one of the
things that we've got to talk about
write down those two terms well unless
you're driving I don't want you to crash
your car but pull over write down those
two terms big government and
authoritarian those are the terms that
the squishes use to make excuses for not
doing anything to stop the left those
are terms that don't mean anything
he's saying that if we engage in the
curriculum battles and and we say that
children should be taught
Reading Writing and arithmetic instead
of how to chop off their genitals that
that's big government
that's just government
that's just
we vote for Republicans to
run the government
and so if they run the government that's
what we elected them to do you need a
government
every society for all of human history
has had some form of government
well that's big government no it's
big
how is it the case
that banning gay porn from schools is
big government
whereas say Banning the Bible from
schools is not big government I promise
you you talked to Larry Hogan you say
hey should we over overrule that Supreme
Court decision that said that you can't
teach the Bible in schools I I would bet
the farm that Larry Hogan would say no
you shouldn't be able to teach the Bible
in schools we have a separation of
church and state we have religious
freedom that would be that would be big
government if we allowed the the
teachers to teach the Bible in schools
again
okay so you can ban the Bible from
schools well how about we ban gay porn
from schools well no you can't ban gay
porn from schools that's big government
well hold on wait hold on it's big
government would be ban
good things Earth it's a big government
when we ban bad things but it's not big
government when we ban good things that
doesn't make a lot of sense to me no
it's authoritarian what do you mean
authoritarian you mean
wielding any Authority well yeah the
Civil Authority has Authority that's why
it's the Civil Authority
civil Authority is a good thing that's
what maintains Law and Order and it's
imperfect that's why we seek to improve
it and we hope to have wise and just
leaders
but simply wielding Authority is not
only a good thing it is inevitable it's
necessary that's what government is man
but no what these guys do and you can
you can always Hear It They'll sound
like they agree with you
they'll acknowledge the problems
the squishiest of writers pundits
politicians they'll say look
a lot of people are concerned
a lot of people are concerned that the
teachers are teaching kids about weird
sex stuff in schools okay yeah you're
right we are concerned so what are you
going to do about it well nothing
because you see the minute we start
doing stuff about problems well then you
know there could be some unforeseen
consequences
well yeah I suppose risk is involved in
any human activity but you're gonna so
you're just gonna let the problem Fester
yeah
yeah because I'll tell you what
if we wield the government to kick the
Liberals gay porn out of schools well
then hypothetically they could wield the
government against us you ever think
about that
uh I have thought about that because
they're doing that right now and they've
been doing it for 70 years yeah well
yeah but imagine how much worse it could
get but I don't know it's pretty bad man
they're transfing our kids they're
shutting down our churches they're
closing our businesses they're
they're calling parents terrorists if
they don't want if the parents don't
want their kids to get trans or be told
that being white is evil and yeah it's I
don't know it's pretty bad actually yeah
sure but think about hypothetically how
much worse again now I'm I'm not worried
about hypotheticals I'm worried about
what the libs are doing right now and
these Republican politicians who
go along with the libs they're the ones
who say well look transgenderism is fine
but this non-binary stuff is just too
crazy they're bad but the ones who
pretend to agree with you and then don't
do anything about it they're almost
worse
because they're just cowards it's just
pure political cowardice
and moral confusion
a refusal to do the most basic thing
that you're supposed to do as a ruler as
a governor which is
pursue good and avoid evil it's the most
basic element of statecraft
speaking of wielding the government
which we need to do
I got an example of a great use of
government that would be in my state of
Tennessee that would be wielded by Bill
Lee Tennessee governor who just a couple
of weeks ago proposed a hundred million
dollars
spending big spending
four crisis pregnancy centers this year
I'm proposing a hundred million dollar
grant program to partner with
non-profits that serve Mothers and
Fathers and Families during a crisis
pregnancy with that our office of
faith-based initiatives has a unique
ability and an important opportunity to
engage non-profits in community
organizations and I believe it's time to
equip them with the resources they need
to play a bigger role as we Endeavor to
better serve Children and Families now
we can and should have
a healthy debate about policies
specifics but we can all agree
that America is rooted in a commitment
to human dignity there was a significant
shift in this country last year when it
comes to protecting the lives of The
Unborn
and we now all
have an opportunity
a moral obligation to support Strong
Tennessee families
my man I love this and I don't want to
hear any squish say this is big
government spending and we shouldn't
have the government yeah it's you should
donate privately to crisis pregnancy
centers you should put your money where
your mouth is to whatever degree you can
if you got one penny to donate or you
got a hundred thousand dollars to donate
give what you can
also we need to make this a public
priority and when it's a public priority
that involves the Public Authority that
involves the government we're spending a
lot of money on abortion Mills in this
country how about we just redirect those
resources to pro-life pregnancy centers
saying hey let's not spend any resources
no resources are going to be spent power
is going to be wielded let's wield it
for good stuff not bad stuff Bill Lee
totally right there I was thinking with
the education issue the debate over the
curriculum Wars
this is a great opportunity here in
Tennessee to push through policies such
as school choice
great opportunity Republicans have
wanted school choice for a very long
time
and it's an issue I think that can unite
the libertarian side of the Republican
party and the traditional conservative
side of the Republican party because
right now the left has a lock on the
schools on the public schools they have
a lock in the public schools because of
bad Court decisions and because of
corrupt politicians and because the
Democrats are owned by the teacher
unions
so what is being taught in the schools
is just awful it's vicious conservatives
have done a pretty good job of working
around the edges trying to ban one book
here trying to fire one teacher or one
course there but it's very very
difficult because there's still so much
power in those Public Schools one way to
take that power away and and put that
power in places where it ought to be
wielded I'm thinking of charter schools
I'm thinking of private schools
parochial schools is to push through
school choice right now
in the Tennessee legislature the
Republicans outnumber the Democrats by
more than three to one in the house and
they outnumber the Democrats by more
than four to one in the Senate this is a
and we've got a republican Governor
obviously this is a great opportunity
it's really important for kids it's a
major winning issue for Republicans it's
one of the most winning issues that
we've got out there and
it
can be done
it can be done right now that would be a
major blow to the libs which rely on
education that's why they always want to
get younger and younger kids is because
the younger children are the more
malleable their brain sourced they want
to set their brains when they're really
really young so that they can put them
on the path toward leftism liberalism
progressivism whatever you want to call
it
we can fight back
we can fight back against that right now
because as I've said for years the
classrooms are crystal balls so you look
at a classroom and it's not as
unfortunately the Boomers and Gen X
conservatives told us years ago they
said all these snowflakes on college
campus wait till they get to the real
world that'll shape them up no what
happened the snowflakes got off the
college campus and then they reshaped
the real world
so what we've got to do is take some
power back in the classroom
Tennessee legislature could do it you've
got my support guys if you want to do it
let's get it done
otherwise you're going to end up with
more political craziness much much more
you're going to see that Overton Windows
shift further and further
and further even the military has gone
woke you saw this
during the Biden Administration you even
saw this under Trump the military
pushing back General milley talking
about white rage remember that the Joint
Chiefs of Staff talking about how how
our servicemen need to focus on the real
issues like white privilege and white
rage and then during covid what happened
our military forced a vaccine mandate on
our service men and women these the
people who are sacrificing their lives
who are who are putting it on the line
for us to protect our country
these are very very healthy young people
generally speaking who faced very little
risk from the Coronavirus
they were told no you have to take the
jab one jab two jab however many Jabs
you can take of this experimental drug
that has
led to I've got to choose my words very
carefully while we're still on YouTube
then we can speak more freely over at
dailywire.com
the jab that like all Jabs has medical
risks and according to reports would
appear to have resulted
in a lot of vaccine injuries well one
such person who is claiming a vaccine
injury is Carolina stancic 23 year old
service member in the National Guard
after getting the primary series of
moderna Carolina suffered heart attacks
a mini stroke
asthma the list goes on Carolina thank
you for coming on the show
thank you Michael I appreciate it so one
thank you for your service two thank you
for helping to expose what seems to me
at best rank incompetence at worst real
corruption in the way that our military
is run what happened to you
um before I start I have to disclaim
that everything that I speak on opinions
thoughts and experiences are my own not
representing the deity or the uh US Army
right what happened to me yeah got the
vaccine was told that you know in order
to stay in the service you had to get
this vaccine uh get it before you are
going to be on active duty uh otherwise
you're not going to recover and so got
it early while I was Drilling and
now I'm two years later not recovering
what what were the injuries what was the
timetable there were going to be some
people who are skeptical they'll say
what the Liberals say which is oh
actually you just had an injury from the
virus not from the vaccine or they they
might say well it's just a coincidence
and there's no data to suggest that this
was from the vaccine so
what's your take right
uh I was working in the ER at the time
and so I got tested all the time for
covid never had a positive test come
back I got tested in the military never
got a positive test back but when I did
get the vaccine I experienced things
like fevers which I'd never experienced
in my life
um it was my first fever I had numbness
uh pressure in my chest asthmatic
complications dizziness a high heart
rate things like that and I didn't
really know what was going on but I knew
that it was weird I was a healthy
individual and so I still don't know
what I was thinking when those things
were happening I was told it was maybe
common maybe just a weird side effect of
the vaccine
how long did those symptoms persist
because of a lot of the vaccine Peddlers
will say well you'll have a couple of
days of discomfort but then it'll all go
away
uh I got it shortly after the first one
within first 24 hours the second one
they had gotten worse and that's when
the fever started
um so that's about a month apart and
then 10 weeks later diagnosed with
asthma so that's 10 weeks in and October
2021 so this is about uh six months
later I had my first heart attack
and just since then it's been going on
what did the doctors tell you after the
heart attack
they were very nonchalant about it
um they didn't seem all that surprised
they didn't think anything of it it
wasn't like oh you're only 21 what's
going on
um I was given drugs uh made me pretty
loopy and then sent to bed rest and I I
just remember like they gave me a lot of
pain medications things like that
do you have a history of heart attack in
your family is there is there any other
explanation that you can think of other
than these shots
100 no never been to the hospital a day
in my life I've been nine times since
then
a lot more I want to ask you about
especially with what's going on with you
now where where you stand Visa be the
National Guard we've got to head on over
to dailywire.com to do that in in no
small part because because we're on
YouTube right now and YouTube doesn't
want these sorts of things to get out so
head on over to dailywire.com the rest
of the show continues now you do not
want to miss it you can go to
dailyword.com
for two months free on all annual plans
we'll see you over there foreign
[Music]